okay
i'm old this time
i'm
lee i'm
white shirt
i'm all right little
lady
yeah turtle wandering in hill ford's
named graham and he is 27 years old
what chad's like wait i had faith in you
i was trying to die the last ten minutes
what do you mean you had faith i had no
faith in you i am praying thank you
thank you
shut up computer
listen to me
keep running is it proximity based it is
can you hear me can you hear me can you
hear me wade
i hear you i'm using proximity based
guys got it now it's more immersive this
way yeah you sound very
echoey and like you're on a webcam like
i know yeah it's weird because my my mic
is good quality and it seems to be
garbling it
does mine sound garbage it sure does my
mic also no
oh yeah oh cool wait are you there wait
are you in here we don't hear you dude
we don't hear you at all no
no no press v
press v
why are you talking through a bed
mattress i it's it's the it's pretty
it's the game man i don't know i'm using
the exact same microphone uh-huh uh
nice pic if you [ __ ] snap pictures of
me get out of here take as many pictures
as i want it's free country i'll take it
i'm taking bottom half pictures of you
hey no don't get my bottom how do you
like top how do you like that how do you
like that how are you fine
yeah well now it's my time
i'm gonna take pictures of your hand how
do you like that all right well i'm a
professional hand model so yeah hide
your hand can't hide your hand can you
get that out of the way can you can't
hide my hand out for me you can't it's
behind me it's behind my back yeah
whatever oh hey
[Music]
i got a picture of it
all right i'm gonna turn that off
[Music]
[Laughter]
my voice chat's disabled i can't enable
it in game i had no way of telling you
all that yeah i don't know i don't know
how bob is he's in purgatory but i think
he still might be talking through uh
voice chat so he definitely is all right
well if he ever gets this message if if
like there were some
beautiful angels out there that were
watching this experience that could
describe it to
hey can you hear me oh hey there he is
yeah my voice is disabled i can't
re-enable it anymore oh okay well we
should just use discord i guess
i had no way of telling you all that
once you were like hey i'm eating
discord talking games
where's the graveyard where's the
graveyard
where wade is i'm alive don't worry
about the map
okay
thanks buddy
orphanage for two things the church and
the borley house
button already baldwin's not i'm going
in
all right well bob you and i will go to
the borlee house that's one of those
okay
i know this i have a funny feeling i
need to take a picture of the mirror
okay i don't think that's right man all
right i did it i got the picture of the
mirror guys
maybe we don't go in there
is it always in the same place or is it
yeah it is
oh well that kind of takes a lot of the
mystery out of it yeah unfortunately
some of the objectives like i said are
once you learn them you kind of learn
them
search wade it's one of those high
queues
a church okay i've always considered
myself more of a loku
yeah
you should try the high q sometimes
hey wait there's um birds falling from
the sky is that bad
that's not good
oh
right here yeah yeah yeah let me snap a
pic bro
there's one right here right above my
head hello oh jesus hey mark how are you
doing hi mark
okay have fun buddy all right thank you
pick a lot of stuff and whatever i will
there's a body in that boat with the
camera did you guys go to the basement
no we didn't no
dude i'm taking pictures of all this i
want memories
it's crunchy in the basement
i'm gonna just move on to get as far
away from mark as possible and go to
church right okay church yeah
yep
[Music]
guys you down here
yeah we're down there buddy yeah
whatever answer you want
oh
what
i'm in the cemetery what are we doing
here okay so listen to the cross with a
parabolic microphone
yeah so if you want to go find the cross
i'll try to keep an eye out for our well
how do i know one of these things with
the sheets on them isn't just the ghost
being really clever
does the ghost seem clever to you
hey wait this is the bridge i was just
on
where should i go back to it
hey um i heard that remark died
hey
well that means we're not dying right
now so that's something hey guys i don't
know do you want to get a sandy colby
what do i i'm not i'm not solving the
mystery what am i
what am i supposed to be dissolving
um that did something yeah i think you
did it because it's dripping blood over
here
but it still is unchecked well there's
all these bodies and stuff cool yeah
these things move we need to go
downstairs oh i don't want to do that
that sounds terrible yeah and also
that's not the way to the cemetery
come on guys
be a friend i'm hearing i'm hearing
stuff hang on
this child yeah there is a ghost child
look at that right here
right here in the creepy oh
look that's the gauge is open oh well
let's grab that aim's harmless
oh it's floating in the air um wade
help it's fine
that's so trapped that's so a trap
don't do it
don't do it it's a trap
it's a trap it's clearly a trap
dad oh you got it
look we go get mark what'd you say
shelby
sandy oh yes sandy colby
is andy colby
sandy colby gotcha
sandy goldberg ain't coming mark i'm not
coming are you back bro
are you coming did you come i came
to the orphanage
yay
into the thick of it
i don't know
i came straight to let's go to the
orphanage is not normally a pair of
sentences that go well next year every
thought is disparate from the other
you don't need to conflate two different
things whoa
hey guys i'm getting an emfp epf what's
this thing it's a reading i'm getting it
thank you for that wait are you not dead
okay i thought he was swooping oh my god
it's a haunted turtle
[ __ ]
guys it's a haunted turtle oh [ __ ] wait
are you jacking me right now i'm i'm not
but i did [ __ ] up
this is a fantastic oh guys guys uh
hello i need a camera camera camera
camera thumbnail one of you is about to
die oh sure
where's the entrance to this orphanage
that is a pretty good thumbnail i gotta
be honest you're all about good backdrop
for the thumbnail good backdrop good
backdrop wait i'm gonna get the crystal
out it's like it's a purple turtle
oh this oh
wait i'm alone where do we go we go to
the orphanage okay bumping these babies
is bad
open these babies bad you're bad
okay
sealed him in by millimeters hey what's
up you [ __ ] all right i'm just gonna
mock you but that's fine you can go i
guess
yeah
i'm so good
oh [ __ ] hey guys down here yeah he down
here i didn't know he could be in one of
these buildings well i guess we got what
we're doing at the orphanage uh solve
the puzzle with the painting in the room
with the mystic stone
well
wade was completely useless there
no
oh what the hell
you should probably sit in that chair i
don't know how i would
instantaneously i would why is that the
solution you came up with is that not
the obvious solution the obvious
solution is
is the steps bad or good or
you want to go up the steps i might do
that
all right i'm going up the steps
i put the i put the circle down that'll
get them that'll get them
mark uh are you solving stuff oh bro so
many stuff
puzzling bro dude who's walking around
with the crystal out i'm walking around
okay
there is something useful here that
you're coming up close to just on your
right you know what adventure is for uh
some adventure
so
take a photo of that no
i'll take a photo of it
oh no i'll take a pho i'll take i'll
take a
it's not gonna get closer
i'll take a photo
i won't [ __ ] help
all right i guess i'm on my own you can
do it mark i believe in you all right
this is great guys all right so did i
solve the puzzle of the one puzzle's
upstairs and one puzzle's here whoa what
the hell
all right guys hang on i'll i'll
if that if i found the way out i would
come rescue right right away where is it
the answer is obvious it's the painting
okay
did you solve it buddy
[Laughter]
lady
hey ma'am oh just go away probably not
supposed to go in there
well
i shoot better than i need sign all
right whatever
mark i
smell imminent death yeah especially
because you're holding a crystal and not
an emf reader or i can see it with my
eyeballs wait did something happen
[Music]
oh it's different now oh
wow
all right how do i get out i want to go
to the cemetery i want to help you guys
you're in a positive orphanage is by far
the biggest location so you're either go
back out the way you came here to go up
another staircase all right okay i'm
trying to come to you guys
hey staircase hey a staircase
do you have a charge in your middle
mouse button um i might what's it to you
you know what you're fine just
yeah i know i'm fine why is there a
submarine door here this place don't
make no sense it's called a hatch
that's the red door that's one of the
possible puzzles here which we didn't
get this time oh puzzles i'm not seeing
a way out
oh not back down mar i'm trying to come
to you guys mar no i'm sure i'm i'm
trying
mar
whoa
[Music]
i'm not seeing anything
did you just watch out for glass and
cans on the way out yeah i think he just
said oops because he just kicked the can
oh yeah
we can't hear it
elevator
what how do i get out of this place you
use the elevator all right
paul's oh yeah that's outside there's
definitely a ghost out here
[Music]
but that can't be right oh
oh now it turns out it's right
turns out it's right okay where is it
ryan
well i've forgotten the names already
jack and kate there's so many
freaking jack northcott and kate camden
how many of these things are there
20 like 20. oh my god
they're in groups of three how was their
25 how was that i think it's five per
row isn't it i don't know man no no man
jack northcutt yay
all right that's one down i have i can't
believe yeah
you guys were right next to each other
oh hell never let go kate
what are we doing we're going to the
orphanage
to the orphanage
hell yeah turtle
turtle oh what's up dude what is up my
dude so we can go right back through the
elevator
i got a job elevator or the front door
either one
are you a chargey boy mark
you chargerific
crunch
all right how do we stop him next time
one of us gives him our butt hole uh if
we have any of the three which mark
since you open that door we should have
charges for three though i got so much
three
the ritual thing we need to put that on
the ground and transform three dude i'm
a three all over them i'm gonna three i
love that for you we love that for us
this is a group endeavor crunch
oh hey guys i'm getting an emp already
[Laughter]
all right hey guys i'm getting an emp
reading oh okay oh easy peasy are you
guys out of three like a bunch of chumps
how did you do that dude
so good this is the red door room which
we don't need for this
the painting room is over here on the
left
this is thanks tour guide
you're welcome thanks pal so in here why
is this room significant
uh solve the puzzle in the painting room
with the mystic stone
1915 what's the puzzle i got no i got
gears oldest to most recent
if i put a thing on the doorways how do
you do that
you're four bro four i'll protect this
while we puzzle this so oldest to newest
yeah should be like 1878. okay you know
it's not really a puzzle if you just
like
yeah that's the answer yeah i messed the
puzzle up already all right maybe you
should give us the puzzle answer that's
what i was thinking that's what i was
thinking yeah i messed i messed it up
already how do i fix it i don't know we
just started really nearly
all right that one
this one that one that one
uh none i win
it's open okay one of us gets a charge
oh
me
see that was great did you see how i i
got our backs i got our backs like that
i got our back good work that was pretty
good man on our left the doorway down
there we don't need to go in there but
that's where the solution is for the red
door room you know all this like
spoilage you know we could find it out
for ourselves and actually play this you
know yeah or you have the time you guys
want guidance
we've never wanted guidance from the
beginning of this all right maybe you
should give us the puzzle catch it at
mark find the kitchen i don't know i'm
going to explore around and i'm going to
find it because it's fun to explore
am i wrong
i don't know i'd like to say hey there's
a guy over here
kill him drink his blood there's a guy
over here there's a mirror it's a portal
oh my god i guess i'm just gonna jump in
oh it was actually a portal
okay
whoa
oh boy that's really ooh
that's fun
okay it's fun
right behind you buddy
that's fun see if we'd just gotten the
answer we never would have saw this cool
stuff
this is true whoa big lady lady
oh see i knew we should be suspicious of
the statues covered in blankets
[Music]
what's in there with you
another one oh it's a painting god damn
it
there's a there's a painting in here
with me you guys want to see a terrible
painting
look to la luna
la luna look at the moon
la luna the moon
look to la luna i'm pretty sure that's
french for the moon
where's the we we're like the basement
of a magical mystery tour where in the
hell would the moon be
i found it hey guys i found a woman in a
in a nightgown you probably saw this
painting
that was the other big lady mark charged
a painting oh well that's oh no i don't
like i don't like getting closer to her
that doesn't make me feel guys are you
in the room with all the faces
no i am now maybe oh i don't like this
place where what are
oh hey
uh
yuck all right
that's how i feel about that
normal reaction
oh yuck gross ew
gross
what a crud muffin
oh are you doing that creepy slow open
mark that's not me it happened
automatically
all right well we just go through there
and nothing bad is happening have we
been here before yes this is where we
first came in
sure came in how do you know you're
gonna go down or do we go down i mean
how do we know because he has the entire
thing solved in his head already
well good for him not all of us are
geniuses you asked the question i
answered it not all of us are g oops
mark why
are you allowed to do things i no one's
stopping me that's why uh huh
uh huh i think oh hey we've been here
before
is this a recipe
i know how to look at this
yeah
dirty fov please
a kid from the academy told me this
story so don't blame me if it sounds
silly he might have been poking fun at a
poor tony but i'm writing this down
because lee needs to know
someone is living in the atlantic island
park wait a minute
what the hell
i know this character
holy [ __ ] i know this drawing it's from
another the park
the game the park that's this
character's from the park
i'm not joking oh this ties into the
park that'd be pretty cool it was his
missing kid and everything about him was
gone is that is that what's talking
about atlantic island park was that the
is this the park
that's crazy that just
yeah there's a video i did it's
literally called just the park i did
like three episodes of it that's totally
him yeah this is totally him about three
episodes
i see see see if we did just gone to the
kitchen
i'm going to go to the kitchen i bet i
didn't wait i did bet you didn't know
about that i did not i've not bought it
also i think our um thing was just used
right here what thing oh the circle
there was a yeah there was a ritual
someone one of you placed that it's gone
now oh oh god i'm trying to sneak up
behind us
all right wade where's this kitchen you
guys almost found it you were right next
to it uh
always happens that way
back down to the
here
ah we should have picked uh we went down
instead up
but we were right here
bob i knew we should have gone down we
came down the stairs and you led us over
here
okay which was right okay
to the right here is the mirror we ran
into right i'm going in the mirror
well bye forever that's cool
this is fun
it's fun
our orphanage is checked off do we need
to do this
orphanages
uh parabolic maximum man
got it
what the frick
heard things no one should open the
fridge without her permission one of you
mark who's got the thingy ghost ghost
ghost ghost
uh did i save him
i think he got it mark did i save you
you did i'm alive
i said where where where you didn't say
anything yeah you didn't really say
anything you know you gotta give some
information sometimes wade
well i got the thing should we get the
hell out of here
yeah
it's okay guys
i know it'll be tough but i think you
can do this without me
oh wait i can revive left we can come
get you yeah it's fine
you'd you'd rescue me
yeah i would leave you all behind oh
[ __ ] oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh
nice work nice work nice nice how do you
know where to go this place is twisting
[ __ ]
well if you have a good sense of
direction like wade
you'd know
sometimes
every now and then i have a good sense
of direction baby touch a baby touch a
baby
wouldn't recommend it
what's your name mark
huh oh
who's your daddy sandy norton
which if i believe is in the second row
somewhere sandy norton got him
thanks thanks man thank you
thank you bro
appreciate you got it bro
i got you don't even worry about it bro
appreciate you bro
bro
where is the nearest altar my dudes
i wish they were some kind of like
distance thing i don't know i think i
think closer to the orphanages where the
nearest one was her where's our turtle
he's right here
oh hey what's up dude
what's up dude what's up i love what you
got going on dude dude never loved a
hairstyle better
you are rocking that [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you have a flash wait behind you
wait behind me you wait wait look out
look out i don't have a flash
come on i'm out of threes i'm trying to
get i was
oh we're out of bringing back thingies
too all right we'll finish this
for you for me for you we'll finish it
for you
this is only halfway
all right hit it
do the thing
yep destroy it kill it do it now throw
it into the fire
door
what are we doing what what is happening
we're just waiting for this toy to be
annihilated
why is it taking so long
together
that's what i meant when i said halfway
how did you know halfway
wade said there's two toys
and that was the first toy oh well maybe
the church is right here luckily so we
can get a charge back no yay we die
if we can't do it without our friend we
don't do it at all no do it all right i
know where i'm going no do it going to
die was that baby i'm gonna take your
time dying i'm gonna go pee i'll be back
oh scarecrow mark you take a photo of
your scarecrow
what about it
hmm
i'm gonna go die all right have fun be
safe
i won't
i won't i feel like the parabolic
microphone should be able to detect them
from afar
oh yeah i i think they're working on a
new map for this i don't know it does it
does detect them from afar
does it
i totally heard something on the
parabolic microphone
and is he coming for you
i mean i heard it from really far away
babies ain't doing nothing i guess after
you know back to back to back to back to
back coming after us he decided to take
a little vacation
where is he
why is this doorway burning
oh
oh no wait no i don't hear anything from
him all right
all right i'm dead
and then there was me
don't kill me
all right you you die good too i'mma go
bathroom as well i'll be here trying to
get murdered you really uh you really
did take your time dying huh
i've been trying
i just got mark a second ago
so weird how mark and i are capable of
dying at will and honestly it's amazing
how good you guys are at dying yeah it's
crazy it's very almost like
sounds like we're really good at this
kick more stuff why are you leaving your
pile of bottles that's the that's the
jams
this guy doesn't even know how to do it
did mark go pee or something no
no oh cause he's right here i was here
you should be right here the whole time
i said i'd be right here and here i am
are you dead yeah you did yeah
just about to die why are you dodging
him okay
you didn't see it he walked into your
screen you didn't see him i was just
looking off somewhere else i didn't
actually even notice him there
well that's what you get for not paying
attention
look i'm crushing you guys on the photos
i just want to say this i am destroying
you guys hey i took i took quality
photos quality over quantity and you
don't know that mine aren't quality and
they are
i do know
yeah it's i think pretty good it's
pretty good
bob crushed us in completing objectives
yeah sucking on that yeah hmm yeah well
i crushed you at listening to
distractible on your favorite podcasting
app
i've never listened should i
yes absolutely you should listen and
everyone and you should make people
around you listen to it you should force
them to listen to it you should tie them
to a chair and shove headphones in their
ears so that they have to listen to it
play it on loop endlessly and on repeat
yeah
that sounds good
[Music]
you